[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
we talk about whatever we want and
sherry cola is here
hello hello thanks for coming thanks for
having me it's my first time were you
bored in the house
i was bored in the house born in the
house board that's so funny that that's
the first thing you've ever seen
of me or no that's the first thing i
ever saw of you and i'm like
this [ __ ] is so funny what is this
that's right tim this is on
a whim tim on on a whim yeah but from
there i went to your page and i started
looking at other stuff
so that was just because there was a
tick tock that was viral with the guy
doing the board in the house and i'm not
even on tick tock at all
uh but my roommate slash very talented
producer
uh musician uh tiff no vanessa michaels
she's like really up on the tick tock
and we just
she makes music so she just made that
video and i was just doing my vietnamese
character
nookie mom
[Music]
and that very good
take the sip jojo take it slow
pick it up slow dip it down dip it down
and then all around
and then take the wrist down to the
elbow and then put it on the palm and
then the fist inside the cup
and then you lick it and then you stick
it
that was nookie mom says like a remix
yeah i guess kind of
you never seen it no no tim it was on a
whim like i
refuse to i refuse to watch other asian
creators content i turn it off
immediately because i'm a hater you
don't want to feel ashamed huh no no no
i know how you feel
legit though like i it was so on a whim
that i was in sweats like not wearing a
bra my hair was still wet like i didn't
think this was gonna
anything oh no bra
no the titties are down to my knees okay
because this was in quarantine
and i didn't touch a bra for seven
months um so the nips were low
and yeah it was low nip sounds like a
vietnamese wrapper too no that was
actually
low nibs actually is coming out with a
mixtape nipple
nipple lip glow man
remember um but yeah i mean it was just
it was just a little cute little
something little remix that's so dope
it didn't even go viral that's what
happens though that's what prompted me
to dm you and like i was in the bed
like laughing and then jill was like
what are you laughing i'm gonna check
this out
and then when i connected with you and
i'm like oh boy from san gabriel valley
too
that's toy 66 for life some reason i
thought you were from the bay or
something
how come i just made it up because i
think most six to
six tricks aren't funny
oh you know why it's because the style
like yeah
you look like yeah yeah yeah the bait
yeah you have the swag
you have this bass swag i dress like
time
pretty much we were literally wearing
the beanies earlier and i was like let
me switch it up man first of all you
know that i only wore a beanie because i
thought there was gonna be a headphone
situation
again so i didn't wear my i always wear
that kind of joe looking hat yeah you
want to use this one can we switch yeah
go ahead let's just switch outfits
completely
no no it's fine i don't know i don't
know what's in that hat i don't know
you're a smart girl man yeah i would not
take his hat
but i would not i don't know what
flavors are lingering okay you guys want
to smell it no
oh i smell my beanie every night and
like low-key like it it's weird it's
like this weird no
do you do that thing where you haven't
washed your hair in like
three to four days and then you and then
you dig it
you dig
i do it all the time there's scalp juice
yeah oh you know when it's so dirty that
you
get that whiff when you make a left turn
i know exactly what you're talking about
that must be long hair problems because
uh
no legit you're just you know the
left not all right the blinker's going
and you know it's coming accurate
you know it's coming and it's the wide
left turn you're like oh yeah
it's about time you hear like yourself
walks in your face it's just no you just
have to i don't know what it is smell
yourself as you go
there's something about the physics why
the left turn why not the right turn
i think you just smelled the back of
your head because you used to be here
right
and then somehow like you now you like
your phantom the physics the phantom
head is now like here
not oh [ __ ] yeah because
you're here and then and then you yeah
something oh yeah because you were just
here so
yeah you're like going into your smell
it's like when you spray the
uh perfume and then you walk through it
yeah kind of the same situation
exactly the same signature
[Laughter]
i know that's what she said oh my
goodness no she had texted me and said
she just said that she did say just say
that uh but no shout out to uh my
my very dear friend vanessa michaels who
actually cut that video together to make
it even
you know as funny as it was bored in the
house just back to that real quick i
haven't seen it
should we play it or what do we have
pull it out how does this work i guess
i don't know tim it's not
and i'm pretty sure we've all learned
you can never plan to go viral
like i can try so hard i'm like this
video is the one this video is the one
that's gonna get me on the ellen show
this one but no
i guess it's that one yeah it's that one
this one yeah yeah okay let's see
i mean i guess basically
yeah it's first of all play from the top
honey you know what i'm saying yeah yeah
yeah
skip it let's get you can skip it around
there's a whole intro to it okay
i like how you switch the lyrics a
little bit it's a remix honey
apparently first of all i actually
downloaded tik tok the day it was gonna
be banned just because fomo
because i i'm not on take talk at all
but you put tick tock content i know
i have nothing on tick tock i just got
the app just because i
have so much data we should have the
uncles meet the niece
oh no but nookie mom at the auntie
oh okay the uncles meet the auntie yeah
so no maybe you have the gf
you have the new gf the girlfriend no
more bingling sal
who the [ __ ] big links how that [ __ ]
it's our old girlfriend
wait no honestly we should do something
we absolutely should do something with
nookie mom i straight up did
i've done nookie mom on on on some
things like you got like
wardrobe and stuff too ish it was like
we got a whole prop closet do you do
skits with her i
haven't done anything i've done her on
uh
you know the show the real yeah i
literally did that [ __ ] character on
the top of the reel
so you stayed in character the whole
time no jud for the oh
the little time um no no they asked
about like a
character i do so i ended up doing it on
live tv which is pretty [ __ ] cool but
i have never really
and you got tia and tamara to laugh at
you um just tamara just tamara all right
um and genie might shout out jesus he
knows which one might be on that day
though right no no tia uh tamara has the
q
a mole yeah that's how i know the
difference anyway but either way they
look really different
the point is um jeannie mai was on it
too and she did a little bit of her
thing obviously
her mom is sick i love her a door a door
um just good people
uh but yeah like uh i've done you know
ig lives and just random
internet videos but not an actual sketch
so
we need to write something we just
should do something but she's older
she's older she's for the record okay
40 50s yeah the uncles are the uncles
yeah really are they 40 50.
you guys were acting like that in your
40s yeah not
us they were no i don't know but i'm
saying you because you're playing
an extension i would love to that you
heard it here first let's do it yeah
let's do like a little trailer
bring it back to the uncles oh i love
triangles some sort yeah
[Music]
like a 90-day fiance trailer
[Music]
that would be tight yeah okay yeah all
right that's it i'm going home
i'm going home i'm done good brainstorm
guys good brainstorming yeah and then we
never do it
that's how i always have hey we should
collab today
this is literally jk yeah
literally someone sent someone tagged me
like a rapper homie of mine tagged me
this morning a story he's like
really wanted at tim chatham to get on
this track but you know maybe next time
and then i forgot that he sent it to me
like a month ago and i was like
yeah bro sick down and then i just
forgot and i was like bro
he was like hey man you know i was just
sending you stuff i thought you might
like i was like bro
i liked it i just forgot like just like
remind me with a text and i'm
and i'm down who didn't forget bieber or
drake yeah
no i'm like that too though i literally
i'll read it and just like now it's red
so i never look at it ever again
reply no i don't oh i don't even reply i
[ __ ] up all the time see that's why i
don't open
look see if you don't open well okay
it does blue the bubble tells you to
check it out see i wish we could
unread text right like an email yeah
so you can remind yourself later yeah
yeah i think you can now so just so you
can read it saying that wait
no no you can't because it's unread or
the bubble oh no you can pin it and
everyone
who the [ __ ] is not whose dick is that
that's not casey that was him
he texted me this morning okay fine okay
fine read it
no that pinning [ __ ] is cool though
that's a cool new thing
did you know that yeah look it shows up
like this
first of all look at my [ __ ] phone i
have a seven plus
oh the new iphones are out do we see
those are they out out
but it looks like this now the the pin
oh it's normal
yeah you can prioritize like you can pin
your priority messages
it's like top eight yeah kind of
remember that
remember that how old are we 22 what
about you
well joe is gen z joe is gen z so he
doesn't know
uh myspace remember my space when you
rank your friends
i remember you're friends yeah yeah yeah
and then they're like how come you don't
have me on the top bait and [ __ ]
and then tom was a mandatory homie no
matter what i unfriended him yeah me too
i in front of him immediately what is
tom doing
today he's traveling the world taking
photos of nature
i think he turned into dan bilzerian but
like before asian girls
i think he's cleaning it oh that guy
while he's doing the beard
what's he doing i think he's cleaning
his butt really well these days oh
oh well he got a tushy yeah i think he's
got we do like a tushy brand here like
we do cause today's video is brought to
you by tushy they hooked me up they
actually sent me
a tushy uh kit and i was wiping my booty
clean it was so nice
but now i don't waste toilet paper or
nothing like that because i just spray
my booty hole with water and you know
you pass the
test if so when i use mine i spread my
butt cheeks
so that my butthole is actually open a
little bit and then i kind of do like
this theme where i go like this
you do it right you go like this like
make sure it's clean all around
the whole thing because there has been
times where i don't do that i'm going to
rush
and my butt cheeks are kind of clenched
so now it's like trying to spit on a
crack and it doesn't really clean the
hole
and then when you wipe you've got dookie
still on the toilet paper it's like
you're the car that goes back and forth
through the wall
through the car wash instead of sitting
there by itself it's hard to believe
that when we go to the bathroom in this
country most of us wipe instead of watch
for years but days have been available
but hideously expensive
costing thousands of dollars i know my
original one was the hellotushi modern
bidet attachment is here to
democratize the blendings the blessings
bestowed
by bidets and offer clean buttholes to
everyone hello tushy cleans your butt
with a precise stream of fresh water for
just 79
it attaches to your existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing and
cuts toilet paper use by 80 so the hello
tushy bidet
pays for itself in a few months because
with hello tushy you don't wipe at all
even the best two ply just can't cut it
when it comes to a hands-free poop
experience stitch paper products and
uncomfortable
chafing when you switch to the soothing
cleansing stream of water
from a hello to sheep bidet attachment
and every hello tissue body attachment
comes with a 60 days
risk free guarantee and a toyama
warranty man what the [ __ ] is so good
[ __ ] join millions of happy hello sushi
customers right now and have a clean
butt with every flush go to
hellotushy.com
off the record to get 10 off 79
that makes like 60 bucks this is a
special offer for our listeners go to
hellotushy.com off the record for 10
percent off
hellotushy.com off the record
i think i would still wipe then bidet
always you're that person that's a waste
of toilet paper
i thought you'd do the taiba day i well
well yes i am that person i am a
wasteful
yes i waste a lot of toilet paper no
same way can i ask you guys something
real quick yeah
do you guys crumple or fold unfold
i'm also a folder i know i'm really bad
i literally do this like
oh really you don't even crumple you're
just kind of like okay well this is a
weird you let it dangle this is a weird
like
size pull the you just pull the roll and
it's like
together and then you just grab it yeah
and then i kind of
yeah but not crumble crumble sounds like
this like cause
what bundle do you bundle what do you
bundle or do you fold
um i'm a bundler but but you know what's
funny because
like i just pull i'm really bad i'm
really bad at conserving toilet paper
but i i pull and use my elbow to cut it
why the elbow boom and then i just yank
it
elbow on the thigh up on the thigh like
that elbow on the
roll because it's right there mine's
right there i don't know where it's
easier when you
fold and cut karate cut no i just do you
fold as
you're you're going oh because for me i
grab and then i i
just yank it to rip it and then i fold
and then i
really i fold and then i cut and then
it's ready to go
i grab i grab four squares yeah mine's
about four too i grab four squares every
time i just take it
fold it and then um i try to use i try
to use that one well you know that first
one is the first wipe is the messiest
one right so it's like disgusting so
yeah yeah so that one
no no folds on that that's right that's
why you should use the bidet first
no see okay then there's the paper
there's also
a risk the risk of a splish splash
situation when it's not all the way dry
wait don't you have ass hairs well
that's what that's when you get the
toilet paper and then you just like
pat it dry if you have ass hairs you're
going to get brush strokes
on your first wipe you
kinds of brown [ __ ] on my toilet baby i
think my [ __ ] hair is
around my hole so it's not as like when
i'm actually like
all of us has that yeah so i have like
three
lucky for you you're lucky i have i name
them
what are they named bart joe tim
that's tight yeah well yeah i mean yeah
well okay so i wipe i well first of all
it's not about conserving paper because
i use a shitload of toilet paper okay
so you're just four squares
one wipe if i if i feel like i need more
which i always do because i will always
double triple wipe just in case
four more squares and then another and
then as i feel it like kind of uh
dissipating i'll use less fewer squares
oh
i have a question yes so uh when you are
wiping and then you you fold it right
and then you're like this
is it just one wipe and get red or one
wipe
and you fold and then you you wipe again
because i folded two i thought like two
or three times yeah well if it's the
first one i don't fold because i feel
like it's a hefty
uh glop in there right because if you
fold the first one that's not enough
surface area a [ __ ] toilet paper
sheet is like that tiny you have it this
big and then you fold
yeah yeah that's what i do i i wish
can we should we take the camera to the
bathroom
do it maybe you got [ __ ] ready you got
[ __ ] locked no i'm ready to go
no so but here's my situation you can't
go straight a day
to wet poop because that causes well
but they blast it off sometimes you have
no proof it's just water
and you clean it up yeah but it's
blasted onto your own ass though like
you're like
like it's like no mine blasts it onto
the
back into the water yeah same yeah what
kind of no as in like
okay if they're strong it depends on the
poop consistency i guess okay let's say
you get a wet poop
right that your butthole has wet poop
this [ __ ] water squirt is going at it
ricochet tiny poop drop onto your butt
cheek
that you don't see pressure spread your
cheeks then you gotta spread your cheeks
and then it will only so now so if your
butt is like this yes you can splat
everywhere but if you spread it so hard
it's flat
then it's like it's only gonna be better
nonetheless i mean unless it's
a powerful stream it blasts it like a
fire hose and it and it cleans it all up
it's like going through the shower
expand your ass cheeks and then the
shower head heads your butthole but then
that goes down into the drain
yeah but it goes down into the toilet
but i'm like this goes up
and down if the bidet was coming from
like down my neck
like like a waterfall then maybe i'll
trust it
but to be honest i know i have used the
bidet my mom has one
i don't personally have one um but i do
the baby wipes and tim and i have talked
about this like
i do oh dry wipe first yeah and then you
know i do that i pull
elbow cut choke myself real quick
and then i wipe dry wipe until dry wipe
is all gone
and then i do baby wipes yeah yeah yeah
yeah and then even
so some of the toilets in thailand i
don't know if y'all have this they got
the little holes attached to the side is
that like no
no y'all don't so in thailand they're
the i tried it there though
oh yeah so you the little there's a
little hose attached to the toilet
and it's oh it's like a spray yeah yeah
yeah so then
you know i would wipe and then when i
feel like i got most of the big poo
chunks off i would use the little spray
as like a bidet situation have the hose
right there
see in china they have a beer bomb
just right there yeah so then straight
so then you just shove it up here
you can tell from the end yeah you need
you need liquid courage to poop
sometimes you get shot
hey larry hold my ankle man
larry where is larry by the way
i don't know we kill barry we kill larry
i think that's one extra too many steps
dude you could just take the hose and
blast it
and then use the paper to clean it up
how to go dry first yeah me too
why though i don't know guys it's gonna
go dry
wet and then dry okay dry wet dry yes
you do that too yeah yeah you gotta be
able to check afterwards too i like how
well i just go
wet and then dry same to be honest i
still have a problem with the lack of
soap here because baby wipes have that
soapy vibe
right like there's a scent to it like
baby yeah yeah you got babies
so with that being said the hose the
bidet is still not enough for me
like it's still like no let's be real
you need a wipe if you get poop on your
hand
you just do water you're good no no you
wipe after
because you got to dry the water too
that's why i get it
and then i put it on my hand on the
toilet paper it is not disinfected
you get listen you get the clorox wipe
the clorox wipe
on your penis the 90 alcohol isocopal
alcohol actually speaking of penis
i'm very curious what it's like to wipe
with balls right there i know me too oh
you go around the back you don't know
you never have it like it's still
just there but yeah do you ever get like
a big space between the balls
well like how like that much like my
whole life i just do it the wrong way
so when i was like when i was a kid i
would wipe my ass so clean but i'm
wiping forward right
and then didn't you bend over yeah and i
would wipe it like this
and then i'm like my ass is so clean and
then i would see like straight up
ball print stamps on my underwear are
you serious
how to wipe your ass this way this woman
told me that he used to wipe his ass
like this
so the ball print poop on the underwear
do you ever look at it like you know
like a psychiatrist test
like the ring test check this out that's
not too crazy because i
like i i for most of my life i was also
wiping
this way right back to front really but
it was like
such a controlled wipe like it was like
almost like
i knew where my balls you stopped you go
down yeah
yeah yeah like at the last at the last
yes it was a like ah you know what i'm
saying
now i kind of do a combination back to
front and i'll go front to back
just to make sure everything wait
question question question
do you do front to back okay wait when
you just pee
yeah you go just front we're also back i
i just go like
all right everything's clean you wipe it
to your ass wait okay that's like you
have long ass arms because i have short
arms
so if you're going from back to front
for the p because with the p hole i just
do
front but i'm just touching the pee hole
because you know what i mean no because
sometimes when you pee it's like a spray
so like you don't know what i think a
little bit of boom boom but once again i
hit
the baby wipe and the you know you guys
don't shake or [ __ ] a little bit
if i have the time no honestly bart if i
have the time
[Laughter]
no if i if i have the time for a little
self-pleasure i will i will spend a
little extra for them it's not some
pleasure
it's like oh instead of wiping you just
shake it can we even like i can't even
wrap my head around the fact that they
don't
wipe yeah that's weird i mean it's a
wiper piece i i
do it now at home if i'm home yeah if
i'm home i'll did you get does the did
you paper get stuck
no it's just a little sometimes do you
get one square
just i literally sometimes i'll rip off
a piece of a square
for the just for the little hole the
piece of paper gets stuck if the seam
allowance comes up and grabs it
there's a venus fly trap
you